not all cannibals are zombies not all
zombies are cannibals and not all
zombies are Undead completely ruled by
aggression as the result of infection
from a biotoxin the infected in the
crazies are unlike many zombies and that
they retain their intelligence and
memory recall they can use weapons and
even drive cars so many people don't
consider them zombies in the original
1973 version of the movie they don't
even look infected but the toxin is
completely in control and that's not to
mention the extreme violence and
frenzied cannibalism by 21st century
terms a zombie is any human living or
Undead who craves human flesh and cannot
control the basic desire to consume